all right hey what's going on everybody
it's bill burns it's time for a very
special edition of the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast
um i'm just checking in on you seeing
how your week's going we have a very
special guest
one of my nearest and dearest and oldest
friends
oldest meaning the longest he's still
he's still quite the looker
he asked me the one and only steve byrne
everybody
yo thanks for having me bill i
appreciate it and i just gotta get this
out of the way
i got to get this out of the way i
watched your episode of snl
i loved it i thought you did great but
the one thing i
really really admired about
your monologue is the fact that i know
that you didn't get to work that
monologue once in the city of new york
normally you'd see rock or whoever's
hosting come down the cellar
and work on it monday tuesday wednesday
thursday friday
at least some of the time you didn't get
any of that and you went up
and you delivered it flawlessly it was
unbelievable
i i i did those pop-up shows
in new york i was going to do a few of
them right
i no i was doing like three at night i
was running
good i was good i ran wow i ran it i did
it uh
um i don't want to get anybody in
trouble because not any all the shows
are legal but just say there was some
rooftops and sidewalks
dude when you did the miranda's behind
plexiglass
i i used to play roller hockey with rick
moranis
in central park and he's the nicest guy
in the world and when you told that joke
i left
twice as hard because it's so damn funny
and he's
just such a good dude well i mean that's
you know if anybody has a sense of humor
that's
i mean obviously i'm not happy that that
happened of course but i'll be honest
with you i thought that that was
going to be the one that people were
going to be upset about
because who doesn't love moranis um
yeah so whatever but i mean that was all
any
you know crap i got for it it's always
like eight people all tweeting at the
same time everybody else either
didn't watch it didn't care or watched
it thought it was okay
liked it didn't like it but is fine with
it
and then you got oh my god i just
anyways
[ __ ] [ __ ] me i wanna talk about you here
well i wanna tell you though i've done
literally this is just today
these are all the radio stations i
called since 6 a.m
5 a.m this morning i've done oh my gosh
22 radio stations
all today yesterday and monday and i'd
say
half of the radio stations i've talked
to probably 60 the last three days
they all loved your snl monologue so
i was going to let you know yeah well
tell them to start tweeting
[Laughter]
[Music]
so anyway um you have an amazing movie
coming out
called opening act starring jimmy yo
yang
i got to do it i think a day or two on
it
um and you have all these amazing
amazing uh people in it a lot of comics
are in it uh neil brennan
who i thought was great i don't i'm not
gonna say who they played on ruining uh
tom segora
whitney cummings eliza schlesinger uh
i'm trying to remember all of them but
uh one of the guys in particular plays a
comedian uh
um alex moffatt who i i just work with
on snl yeah much as i loved his
performance in your movie i was even
more blown away when i met him because i
didn't even recognize and i just watched
the movie
because i was in there i go how did you
do something i played the uh the middle
the feature act
and i and i was like and i and i said oh
yeah and then i was thinking my head
like
wow man he looks totally different he
sounds totally different
and i we did a few sketches together i
think one that made the air
and um he really is like different in
each thing so
the mob scene one yeah yeah he's such a
great actor
really great yes he is there's a lot of
uh
super talented people over there but for
those of you who don't you know
obviously opening act it's about stand
up
i'm assuming steve it's loosely based on
obviously your career as a
comedian of asian persuasion right
trying to uh
get some stage time out there that's
right yeah semi-autobiographical i think
it would be
you know when i was writing it i was
like i want to write a great film about
stand-up i hadn't seen
a great film just dedicated just to
stand up and i thought
i don't want to watch a film about a 50
year old driving home from vegas i want
to watch a film about a 20 year old
driving to las vegas for the first time
so why not experience everything for the
first time with this character from
bachelorette parties to heckling to
doing morning radio for the first time
so everything that happens in the film
did actually happen to me the scene
where jimmy ends up underneath the
trailer scared for his life
in the woods while a couple above him is
having sex that happened to me
and it was a marine way yeah it
and when i when the girl brought me home
it was from charlie good night because
remember
charlie good night's the club was
upstairs you go downstairs and that was
the club where everybody partied so you
go downstairs like fish in a barrel and
this girl
she's on the bar daisy duke's cowboy hat
on
she points me she goes you get over here
and i was like
yes ma'am and next thing i know i'm on a
highway
i'm on an interstate i'm on a main road
i'm on a side road i'm on a
dirt road i'm in the [ __ ] woods and
i'm like where the [ __ ] are we
and i'm literally in the woods and i go
into a trailer she pops open two beers
we're drinking beer she
immediately grabs my pants and pulls
them down i mean we're in there for a
minute
and i'm looking at the desk and i see
all these guns and this bullets and i'm
like
are you do you shoot guns and she goes
oh no that's not mine
and then all of a sudden i hear a truck
pulling and she goes
oh my god my boyfriend's here i go what
he go she goes he's a marine get out of
here
and i jumped out of the window and i'm
in the woods
so i can't run anywhere because i'll
snap branches he'll go what the hell is
that and it'll shoot me
so i sat under the trailer and i heard
him
talking to her about i was gonna bang
her and all this stuff and
then they started having sex and i was
just like oh my god and i didn't have a
sleepover how long were you underneath
the you never told me this how long were
you underneath the trailer for
i was underneath the trailer for
probably three hours
i didn't have a cell phone because this
took place in the year 2000
and so i had to wait until they banged i
heard them making hot pockets they ate
they passed out
i ran another two hours to the gas
station
and that's how i got home it was awful
awful
at one point did you fee i mean you must
have been scared
shitless with the guns because
they killed you he could have shot you
as many times you want no one's gonna
hear it out there
no and then just bury you i mean it's
over
yeah i think in some way my career was
is still left under that trailer i think
that's what happened
wow you know uh that room i'm not going
to say the comic's name that reminds me
another time when we
we were in uh somewhere in tennessee
and the comic i was working with
black dude left with a married white
couple
and i was just like are you out of your
[ __ ] mind
are you out of your mind i was like dude
don't go and he was just like nah man
it's fine it's fine
and then it ended up being fine it ended
up being fine there's some uh
there's some pretty wild people out
there that's what i i mean i'm so glad
dude i was just
i mean if i didn't go to the bar and get
shit-faced i just went back to the room
i
i never got you know the few times
i tried to stick my toe into that that
world i always met some psycho chick and
i was just like i i really don't want to
be meeting the kind of person that that
is going to hook up with the comic
that's coming through town
yeah so i i kind of stayed out of that
world jesus dude that made me nervous
when you under the how did you know
when you finally felt like okay they're
asleep
i didn't hear anything i didn't hear
anything for like a good 20 minutes i'm
like i think now there's
now they're sleeping and it had to be
like five or six in the morning
i was scared out of my mind i was a
young kid and again i didn't have a
selfie gotta make a move before the sun
comes up
[Laughter]
it was it was horrifying and even like
that radio scene in the film that
happened
in los angeles at klos uh
on frank heidi and frosty and we're
friends now but
it was the second time i did radio and
again
it's a different muscle you got to know
how to do radio and
jimmy doesn't know and i didn't know in
the film jimmy doesn't know
so i'm bombing on the radio i start
trying to do that new york celery to set
it up there's a scene where
uh jimmy's character is going in for the
first time he does morning radio meets
like a morning zoo team
yeah and you know they've been doing it
forever and you come in they don't know
who you are
and those things can go sideways really
quickly sorry so go ahead
it went south quickly for me and and i
started trying to do the seller [ __ ]
where i'm like taking jabs at them
but i wasn't doing a good job at it and
they're like who is this guy
they called security on me while i'm on
the air they go
security can you i'm like are you guys
serious i thought it was a joke
security comes and like picks me up and
i'm like is this real
and i i get taken out i get escorted out
of the building is this a bit
i got i remember at the time sebastian
maniscalco lived
a block away so i walk over to his place
i knock on his door he goes what's wrong
i go turn on the radio
we listen to them eviscerate me for 15
minutes destroying me he's got no
charisma he's got no future
this is in los angeles how hard were you
laughing i was crippled i just moved to
l.a i'm like
oh oh okay okay this is the worst
they stopped they cut to commercial
sebastian just put his coffee down he
looked at me goes
what the [ __ ] did you do guys
so the film was really taken all those
awful experiences and combining it in
the 90 minutes so that
people that have been to a comedy club
can now experience what it's like to be
on the road
and also how difficult it is to navigate
those
first very few few moments and hurdles
we all have to go through
as young comics yeah i remember
uh doing a radio
with this there was some legendary guy
in cleveland i should have known
because he was like in his 60s
he was still doing it i remember he had
he had brown hair that he had
dyed it and somebody had an orange tint
to it you know they
die wasn't good in the 90s right yeah so
i went on
and he was just he wasn't friendly and
he had this sidekick and he was like
hey he goes he goes hey how's it going
and i try to do it
yeah it's going great let's get the
comedian up at six o'clock in the
morning i just i try to do like a
i'm so tired but he took it and so i was
[ __ ] on his show
oh and he i
don't even so long ago he just started
coming at me and by the time i was like
oh no no no that that was aimed at me
yeah
it was i did another one
um this shock jock guy
i came walking in and he's got his back
to me i already gone through there one
time
yeah late great charlie murphy and
donnell
rawlings when we won the chappelle's gig
uh tour
and i went in there and he was
intimidated by
charlie and donnell right those white
guys i felt like didn't hang around
black people so he's like oh my god
black people
be friendly and i was sitting there you
know looking like a
old howdy duty so he just was going at
me
so i kind of knew he was like that and
the person was bringing me
yeah he's kind of in an extra grumpy
mood so i came walking in and the guy
is back to me doesn't even say hello
and they got me a water and like bill
you got we gotta water can we the
assistant's like can we get you anything
else
and i was just like nah man i just need
some headphones and i'll be good
and he turns around and goes yeah we'll
get you some cans go get your hands
like who says cans right and i was just
like
what the [ __ ] and
he ended up getting fired shortly
thereafter and i think he knew he was
going to get fired so he was in this
desperate mood
where he had to be crazy and i he threw
a whole hot cup of coffee
i think it was still hot at one of his
lackeys oh [ __ ] really
threw it up and over like we were
standing like a round thing yeah
he didn't throw it he he made sure he
threw it where it was it was sort of
going
up and the kid had time to get out of
the way but i was just like
this guy's out of his mind trashed me
said he never heard of me and i said
well i just had something
come on i go at that point it starts
sticking up myself well actually i know
i
just did premium blend or something on
comedy center i got good reviews or
something like that he goes yeah well i
never heard anything about it
and i'm just like uh thanks
just one of those idiots who like
doesn't get the business because it's
like
you know you stay in this business for
15 minutes
and you're gonna see somebody that was
here go down here
and somebody here is gonna go like that
so anybody you're talking to
if you're looking up at him looking down
the next day it can flip so
if you go around doing this thing where
if i don't know you i'm gonna treat you
like [ __ ] that guy could end up being or
that woman could be a boss
in like a week and for some reason this
guy uh
didn't seem to understand that no not
like that happened with me but i would i
just i've never understood people
you know just in general to treat other
people like [ __ ] but just if you have
any sort of business sense why you would
do that
especially in in our profession because
we're all stocks we go up we go down
like punky johnson you think about it i
asked her she was a bartender
at the comedy store and i said hey we
got a scene where i need
a host of the open mic and she's the
host of the open mic at the beginning of
the film
she's introducing dr ken ken jung and
she's up there
and now the film has come out and she's
on snl
and i was like holy [ __ ] just in in in
less than literally the last time i saw
her
she was behind the bar at the comedy
store going what's up bill
i saw him you know right before covid
yeah and that was the things for those
who don't know she would be
she would work the bar early in the
night and then she would run up and go
do a spot and everybody loved her i mean
that she was one of those
people that when she got it the whole
comedy store
yeah just texting each other like what
oh my god like everybody loves her or
not i actually got to do
um i got to do a sketch with her yeah
yeah so it was kind of cool in the end
dude
i mean i was with you when we we were
talking about kevin hart when kevin hart
first did snl
we had a conversation about that was
like one of the first of our friends
to kind of host and how cool it was and
man i think it might have been dane it
was dane or kevin got it first yeah
yeah and then and then you got it and
then to see
like when i saw the thing they always
have great photography
and yeah they put on the social media
the yellow background and you were there
and i was like man that's so [ __ ]
cool that uh
all those all those great the pantheon
of talent that's been on that show
i mean i know you well when i was
getting changed they were on commercial
break i peeked out for some reason
because i was you know music geek i was
watching the band
and uh oh jack white jesus man yeah i
i saw i was watching i think the snl but
i saw the
that one with the yellow background and
said snl and i was just like
this can't be real this is what i want
16 birthday and let's let's pretend you
did this show
it was crazy i want to ask you this
because obviously you're such a big
music fan i
i want to hijack your podcast but the
guy the drummer that was playing with
jack white he i've never seen like an
inverted drum kit where it was facing
out is there
an acoustic reason to do that or is it
just like an aesthetic reason to do that
i've never seen that in my life
i i read up on it there is like a reason
he said he did it
yeah um but
i can tell you that i got so many
people who said hey great job on snl
dude what was up with that drummer's kit
i mean it was nuts uh jeff cesario was
telling me
he goes it looked like he was playing
like drums while falling out the window
but he i mean
it works for him he had all kinds of
things when he would hit the ride he
kind of go like that with this
he was really interesting to watch but
didn't
steal focus and they played off each
other great and then their bass player
the bottom end that he was putting in
that like i got
um like i was already
on ten and then when jack showed up
yeah and your dressing room's here his
is like literally
right there oh by the way this is my my
snl
cut i got what happened that was from
the cast
on the uh sam adams thing they had the
fake cast and
when we mean like they were fighting or
whatever so some point it
it just it was like like a cheese grater
[ __ ] thing has been so annoying to
try and get to heal because it's
i don't know why but anyway um
once he showed up uh
i mean the ride he takes you on like i
love that one song when he just start he
starts so low
and then we just let a couple like bend
a few notes a few ring out and then just
build build build i mean um
yeah i learned i i was talking to
somebody last night about this
i learned the most lessons i learned
about a comic
is from watching great musicians it
makes no sense
but it does to me yeah
if i see like you know
just the the dynamics if somebody who
understands dynamics understands how to
pull it back and then unleash it
just because they're doing the musically
you can do that also with
your jokes and how you control your
energy how loud you are
bring them down which pulls them in and
then hit them over the head
and then you can't stay up at 10 for too
long or it just becomes like white noise
and
um you know we've all seen like the loud
comic who has the mic
like in their mouth yeah and it's like
that only has an effect
you know for so long but if you have the
ability to do that it's this amazing
tool
that you can then have that overhand
right to hit him with
so i i get a lot out of like
just how hard he was going yeah and how
amazing they sounded
i was just thinking like all i got to do
is nail
my monologue and then in every sketch
i'm in
i'm surrounded by groundling second city
or yeah
they're gonna hold me up and then i'm
gonna say now jack white
unbelievable he's gonna [ __ ] kill it
and then i knew that
uh uh beck bennett had this really
really funny pre-taped thing so i was
like we got that
and i was that's when i like around
friday i was getting excited i was like
this
is going to be this is going to be this
is going to be
interesting and then i saw the eddie van
halen tribute that video
which i didn't know that they were going
to show and i was like
it was it was unbelievable moment that
was sick
and it's great that someone who's a
purveyor and such a fan of
of rock as you are was there to you know
pay homage to him and and to say what
you were saying about
deriving inspiration from music i
remember watching that
michael jackson documentary this is it
remember after he died they cashed in
and showed up rehearsal [ __ ]
and there was a moment in there where he
he comes out and the band starts playing
goes no no no no
let it sizzle me
let it simmer yeah and and i remember
like
i laughed so [ __ ] hard and then i was
performing like the next week at a funny
bone
and i nailed the joke and the audience
was clapping and in my head i heard his
voice go
let it simmer and i was just like
i just like don't talk and let it sit oh
that's what no i'm telling you like
those guys
like if you see a master i'll tell you
who i saw was a master
that not the most popular guy anymore
yeah but i saw bill cosby right before
right before all the the [ __ ] hit the
fan and i watched him sit down
doing that oh yeah he had us on a string
yeah he had us on a string and wherever
he wanted to take us
he was it was he was like conducting the
whole thing
and i got so much out of watching that
so um i don't know but anyway let's talk
about the movie here dude this ain't
about me when
when is um when is it when is it out how
can people see it
yeah when do you go to cons and be
called the next
none of that's happening bill none of
that's happened and when when the film
got great
driving movie theater bert christie
opens
the movie goes on that's what's going to
happen i'm i'm going to go see
i'm going to have a premier biwi big
peewee's big adventure
style you know where i'm at the end and
i walk through the drive-in and all my
friends are there that's what's going to
happen i
got a tuxedo i got a nice dress for my
wife
and i was like we're going to wear this
to premiere to the premiere and then the
pandemic hits it's like
well we're going to get a six pack of
schlitz and pop open this suv and just
watch it
from the back of the suv but yeah it's
going to be uh
friday october 16th in select theaters
which means if you want to see it in
theater you got to fly to a red state
and watch it there
or you just watch it uh amazon and
itunes anywhere
there's no problem there's no driving
movie theater premiere in l.a
nope nah man because i once you said
october 16th i'm like well
i got past that gig and my year i got
all all the time in the world
yeah we're gonna i think we're gonna go
to um i'll let you know about it but
vince pete and i are gonna go to one of
the drive-ins and some of the cast
members i'll let you know
which one we're going to but i think
we're going to just get a limo and go up
and
there yeah yeah it'll be it'll be fun
man it should be yeah i got to ask you
uh in an earlier draft because i know
some steve burns stories here oh boy
[Laughter]
in an earlier draft was there ever a
scene
where jimmy's jimmy's character will
is on stage and a puerto rican hits him
over the head with a uh with the chair
at a club that may or may not look like
the comic strip
now for those of you at home this
this this man may not have happened to
uh your director here steve byrne he was
uh
at the comic strip and um one of the
great comedy clubs out there but as all
comedy clubs they go through you know
ups and downs just like a relationship
that's down
time and you wanted to be on the eight
o'clock or the ten o'clock show you did
not want to be on
the late one in the late one what would
happen
was so few people would show up
that until you hit a comedian over the
head with the chair you were not going
to get thrown out
so you just went up there there was
nobody going in there
looking out for comics nope now they do
i'm not [ __ ] on the club but that
there was a period back then
where you went in there you were on your
own and you would walk in there and you
could tell
the crowd had already taken over the
show everyone was julius caesar doing
this
i had i i stopped putting in for the
late show i stopped putting in for
because i just
at some point i was like i've done this
enough i have my stories i've paid my
dues i'm getting nothing out of this
yeah and i'm going home angry because it
would always be the last set of the
night
i i learned my lesson the hard way and
everything you're
saying tell us how did that happen
i went to the late show i i was such a
[ __ ]
i was a young comic i wrote a new joke
that day i'm like i'm gonna grind this
joke and by the end of the night
it's gonna be a good joke so i did my
sets i go up to the comic strip it was
my birthday too
so i go up of course midnight
there's eight people in there four of
them are from
jersey and they're debating the check
that's how late i was up i got the check
drop
and so they start bitching about the
check and i go guys can i
just do this show for these remaining
four people what are you gonna do about
it jackie chan i'm like oh [ __ ] here we
go
so they called me i thought it was i
thought you were the one i thought that
was the puerto rican guys that must
meant somebody else
no well no you're right so they call me
jackie chan they call me something else
then the girlfriend starts chiming in
the girlfriend's chirping me this
italian chick
and i and i was so inexperienced i was
such a dummy i go will somebody tell
that [ __ ] to shut up
next thing i know a [ __ ] bar stool
gets whirled right across z
z i see it in slow motion i turn
around the bar stool hits me right here
cracks my skull open
no blood is streaming down my neck like
hot water
big j okay heard that this little crash
against the wall
comes running in breaks it up i go he
goes you okay i go i'm finishing my set
he goes you're not finishing your set
dude you got blood coming down your neck
get the [ __ ] in the hospital
he burns a hockey player by the way go
ahead yeah so
so i go to the hospital eight staples in
the back of my head
and being a comic i'm like they're not
gonna bog me down
i know i'm embarrassed but i gotta go
show my face and get it over with
i show up as soon as i walk into the
comedy as soon as i walk into the comic
strip they go
hey everybody it's the chairman the
chairman is
steve burns here i go all right i walk
over to my headshot
somebody had taped staples to my
headshot right there
i remember all right welcome to new york
city
i think that's how i found out about it
why is there staples on steve byrne's
head because i think i was on the road
they didn't hear about that
he called this puerto rican guy's
girlfriend a company
and then i was probably going and what
did you guys do about it
i love it once again they even threw a
chair and nobody can
the other comic yeah yeah we had jay
that came in and said
yeah i believe you know there was one
time i got into a
a real fist fight at the comedy store um
i'll never forget this
i i was at a point in my life where you
think okay i'm mature enough
i'm past it i know how to handle
situations
it was a student at the comedy store
this is the dark days of the store
nobody's coming there right
and so i'm being introduced as i go on
stage
four kids four asian kids are getting up
and they walk out of the comedy store
and before i even touch the microphone
this guy goes hey your friends left you
i go what he goes your friend's left and
he's eating chicken wings
now after he says your friends left he
goes like this he goes
and i was like this [ __ ] i go
are you saying my friends because
they're asian
he takes another bite of the wing and he
goes yep that's what i'm saying
i was like this piece of [ __ ] i go well
maybe i'll go outside and i'll find him
he goes maybe you should i go maybe you
should come outside with me we'll find
him together he goes
maybe i will and i
jumped off stage this guy i jumped off
stage
i got up he got up i started walking
over towards that corner by the
by the uh manager desk or whatever where
they answer the phone and take the money
and i grab him and i just start popping
him in the face and i'm dropping him i'm
popping him as he goes down i'm just
drilling him next thing i know his
friend
that was with him picked up a table
those tables are heavy they've been
around since the 50s probably anybody
knows about the furniture at the comedy
comic strip that we use steve you got a
bar stool now we got a table
okay i got a table yeah this guy's
taking a table and he's going to hit me
brett ernst runs in and tackles the guy
and puts an end to that otherwise i
swear to god i would be eating every
meal out of a straw i'd be up on four
wheels
that thing's [ __ ] heavy so thank god
brett ernst saved me
big j saved me and uh that was the last
fight i got into
uh because of comedy i learned my lesson
i know one other one but i'm not uh
what other what other one that guy on
ninth avenue sitting in the car
what happened
i i i remember i thought you don't
somehow you got into with a guy in a car
yeah and you punched him in the face
while he was sitting
oh that meant yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then there was another time outside the
cellar
outside the cellar the cab driver was
being a [ __ ] [ __ ] so i took
you know they took the garbage bags i
took a garbage bag and i [ __ ]
chucked it on the hood of his car like
[ __ ] you you piece of [ __ ]
and he got out and i started hitting him
and he hit me back and i
i think it was colin that broke it up
colin quinn and uh
he's like you're good i'm like yeah i'm
up in five minutes and
this is just one of those things i think
i'm the only guy who never had to break
up with steve
the mother that i hung out with you you
never got in a fight when i was around
you but i would just always
i'd always say yeah steve uh i don't
know steve went into they
went into the wiz to go buy a uh to go
buy
uh walkman i'm a pretty nice guy but a
speaker at the back of his head and he
just started punching him
it's always just right there it's always
right there i'm a great guy i'm a good
hang but it
there is that like it's right there just
always boils it's a nice simmer but as
i've gotten older the simmers got lower
and lower
that's the etsy of blood man it's the
irish it's the korean in ireland irish
in there
because the queen's are they green and
irish right koreans are the irish of
asia
um they're outgoing they're fun they
love to [ __ ] drink whiskey oh my god
they're storytellers and they love to
fight so i think it's
it's a double whammy got a double shot
of hot blood is what happened
you know who else has that you know who
else has that is al madrigal
oh yeah but he's not he's sicilian and
mexican
oh you do not want to you don't want to
make him mad
no you never want to get on al's bad
side he's the most brutally honest
person i've ever met
he likes he likes to talk [ __ ] but he's
he does it from an honest place but he's
never been in a fight which i found
fascinating then you go
the way you write enough i go the way
you were on your mouth you never been in
a fight he's like
never been in a fight i guess he's one
of those guys that doesn't need to
well it's good he did because he's he's
like one of those bite your ear off guys
he starts biting your ear and you pull
away doesn't let go and then it's like
three quarters hanging off your [ __ ]
head yeah
yeah there's no there's no rules of
contact with him i think
yeah i essentially retired from fighting
in like junior high everybody else hit
puberty but me and shot up
and i was like all right time to be
funny
let's avoid this i think my late 20s
that's when i that's when i
raised the it raised it to the raptors i
retired from fighting from then
yeah it's a great thing to do um anyways
the uh i love the movie i saw it and i
didn't get to just talk
cedric the entertainer as the the
the headlining comic taking jimmy's
character will
under his wing um was such an
amalgam of so many people that helped me
out
in this business all the way from tony b
when i was in boston to like
dice out in l.a um just giving you
sage advice you know
yeah and i really now that i've gotten
to that age is what it is when you look
at younger comics
you see them about to do something that
you did
yeah and be like all right you can do
that but
you know my experiences it played out
like this
or you can do this other thing um
it always helped me out as a younger
comic because it was like okay so this
is not
unique to me the world is not attacking
me
this is part of being a comedian and you
can just
then you don't have to do all that
stupid guy ego [ __ ]
um that causes you to say something
stupid
and basically put you on the bench for
another three years in this business
yeah and story to go away or for
somebody to do something dumber than
whatever the hell you just did
or said yeah all those all those great
guys along the way but now it's like you
and i are
at a similar age now where look you're
doing theaters and arenas i'm still in
the clubs and those young comics come up
and they still ask you i'm in parking
lots i'm doing patches of grass
behind a [ __ ] motel we all we all got
me too this year
covid meet everybody
well the young comics they still ask you
those same questions
and now it's like i finally we will be
able to say here's a dvd of the movie
that's everything you need to know good
luck on your journey i think the film
it really is enough for a young comic it
really isn't um
i've never written a movie but i i
talked i mean i can't imagine how much
work that was i'm so proud of you
everybody please go out and go see
opening act
where can they watch it online did we
mention what that was yeah streaming
amazon itunes wherever you stream films
uh you can see it october 16th it's
released and i cannot thank you enough
for doing it bill
uh you know it was one of those things
where yes you are a friend but it was
also a favor because you're doing so
much it's like
you got your pick of the litter and to
go from you know like set of the
mandalorian to coming down
and doing an independent film with me
and jimmy oh yang which i never
understand
are you being confused with the other
jimmy yang that's so famous and popular
i never understood why he has the
o in there but it's like all right let's
do jimmy oh yeah
thank you man thank you for doing it no
worries no worries um i hope this is a
big success and like to see many more
the great steve byrne everybody thank
you bill
no worries and i'm gonna have to do
advertising reads after this
all right any other thing if you need me
to instagram anything tweet anything
just always text me and i'll i'll help
promote it you got my
you got my number steve so if there's
any promotional stuff they i'll just
add to the tweet let me know okay yeah
for sure i'll i'll hit you guys up
probably day of you know the day of
release i'll hit you guys with maybe the
trailer asking just put out the trailer
and see
that's in two days the 16th right two
days yeah man dude congrats on snl dude
i was so [ __ ] happy for you when i
saw you come out and do that monologue
it's just like there's a part of me
up there you know because every comic
wants to do that
but knowing like one of the good guys
got to do it i was so [ __ ] stoked for
you man
and that that boston that sam adams
commercial was so
[ __ ] funny i was i hope you're proud
of that because that
i hope they do an extended cut because i
had a lot of
we had a lot of fun doing that we shot
that for like four hours i had all kinds
of
ultimate endings and all kinds of things
i was just that heidi um
the actor there her last name she was
cracking me up she was super funny too
so
love to your family man love to you take
care guys all right we'll see you
all right ladies and gentlemen it's our
old friends here in no cheeto
you know people finding clothes that fit
you
just right can be incredibly challenging
they should be the people sewing them
together
indochino suits are great for weddings
and work
and they even offer casual options like
shirts coats and chinos
so i guess it is chino with indochino
uh you get custom fitted suits and coats
and casual wear at surprisingly
affordable prices
customize everything from the fabric and
the lining to the lapel
shape and monogram and since your order
is made to your
exact measurements it always fits you
perfectly
if you're getting married maddie geez
indochino is no longer as a no-brainer
for you you and your groomsmen
forget the off the rack suits that don't
fit different type bodies
you know what that means you're tall
you're short you're a little chubby
uh indochino gives everyone a tailored
fit
order with ease and get it shipped fast
no matter where you live or you feel
like kevin mchale with super long arms
um and with all the ways to customize
you can add a personal touch to
everything and
and every personal touch everyone will
be proud to wear without emptying their
pockets
the best part is indochino suits start
at just 299
with all customizations included visit
one of indochino showrooms across north
america
or book a virtual appointment at shop
online at indochino.com
and right now you'll get 30 off any
purchase
of 3.99 or more when you enter the code
bur burr at checkout that's
indochino.com
oh no indochino.com
promo code burn sorry oh look who it is
everybody
oh zip
uh monica stacks could relate
she needed to hire for a pivotal role at
her construction company
gs group but was having a tough time
finding the right person
especially with so many candidates out
there so she
switched to zip recruiter zip recruiter
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them for you
it's technology identifies people with
the right experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply which
is why you should try zip
yeah for free at zip recruiter.com
that's how monica found lamont your big
dummy
jenkins who's named lamont in 2020.
she said that zip recruiter sent lamont
i'm having a big one profile to her
around
wait she said that zip recruiter sent
lamont's profile to her
around five minutes after she posted her
job
because he was a great match for the
role though zip
uh through zip recruiter monica's
company has hired everyone from
accountants to project managers to field
scientists uh wow that's a big
construction company
but monica's not only the only employer
who loves zip recruiter four to five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
see for yourself how zip recruiter makes
hiring faster and easier
try it now for free that's right free at
ziprecruiter.com
i p r e c r u i t e r
dot com slash bur b u r r okay
we got one more here hello fresh hello
fresh
uh get fresh pre-measured ingredients
and mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door with
hellofresh
america's number one meal kit hellofresh
lets you skip those trips to the grocery
store it makes home cooking easy
fun and affordable let's get the grocery
store how are you gonna find that
married woman in the loveless marriage
sorry hellofresh offers convenient
delivery right to your doorstep for easy
home cooking with the family the recipes
are easy to follow and make
and quick to make with simple steps and
pictures to guide you along the way
hello
cuts out stressful meal planning jesus
christ what am i going to make
and grocery store trips so you can enjoy
cooking and get dinner on the table in
about 30 minutes or even less
easily change your delivery days or food
preferences and skip a week whenever you
need
feeding the whole family has never been
easier
with larger box sizes for more servings
and more savings
since they offset their operations
travel and shipping admissions
hello fresh hello freshers carbon
footprint is 25 percent lower
than store-bought grocery made meals
the source of that is the university of
michigan hail
to the victors hellofresh is committed
to making fresh
delicious food available now more than
ever and has taken extra steps to keep
its employees and customers safe
including contactless delivery here's
your food
tamper-proof packaging and team member
wellness checks
you can save 40 by using hellofresh
versus shopping at your local grocery
store and it's more convenient too
over 90 percent of ingredients are
sourced directly from growers to ensure
the freshest recipes are delivered to
your door
um host must voice call to action
verbatim
oh that's me i'm the host and i must do
the
the call to action verbatim well i'm
gonna if you write it i'm gonna read it
go to hellofresh.com slash eight zero
burr and use the code eight zero
burr to get a total of eighty dollars
off
across five boxes including free
shipping on your first box
that's hellofresh.com eight zero bur
promo code eight zero b u r r
thank you for listening enjoy the music
and there'll be a bonus
half hour of a thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcasts
from you know
a year ago or i don't know how andrew
does it he 58 years
eight years from eight years ago all
right
when tom brady was still a patriot okay
i'll see
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday october 15th
2012. 2012
baby um
this is soulful october make sure to
wear your
fake pink afros for to raise
soul awareness in october
i want to [ __ ] have some sort of
counter
uh awareness thing to try to dip into
all this pink
all this pink that i'm seeing out there
it's like i got it
i was aware of it before the month
stop jamming it down my throat there
you know we already got a month of it in
the nfl
breast cancer we're raising awareness
why don't you raise money to cure it
isn't that what you're supposed to be
doing if you're raising awareness what
exactly does that mean
they said that on my flight i was on a
delta flight
you know went to the airport and i'm
flying
once again come fly with me
you red face [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i'm flying from
new york city to los hangales right and
i get on the flight
and i'm looking at the ladies right the
stewardesses and they're sitting there
in
jeans and in pink shirts and i was like
oh geez
right here we go again here we go again
all right so we sit down and they get on
the fl you know they get on the [ __ ]
horn there
and they go thank you for flying gel
tough you could step
out of the aisle to help expedite
[ __ ] word i can't stand that word
does not exist
other than in the [ __ ] corporate
world all right
to expedite the boarding process
we'd like to have an on-time departure
[ __ ] that's not on me that's on you
okay you said the [ __ ] was leaving it
[ __ ] 10 past 11. i didn't
why didn't you start boarding the
[ __ ] thing earlier or at least give
us a little more room back here
so anyways of course once we get the
plane starts going
she goes um the captain still has the
seat belt signs on you cannot use
anything electronically here's my
memorized joke that i say every flight
about electronic stuff
and then she goes you might have noticed
um
the flight attendants are not wearing
our usual uniforms
really yes really
we're actually wearing jeans and pink
shirts
to raise breast cancer awareness if
you'd like to buy
a ham sandwich that was put together by
a filipino child
nine weeks ago out in the french riviera
sweatshop
section of nice
a portion of the proceeds will be going
towards raising breast cancer
awareness they keep saying that [ __ ]
raising breast cancer awareness
shouldn't they be raising money to cure
it you know i think the awareness is out
there so if you're just raising money
if i go and buy that [ __ ] cubano
[ __ ] you know ham and cheese with the
pickles there
sandwich right i'm buying it thinking
that i'm going to help the [ __ ]
disease
am i if you're just doing it to raise
breast cancer awareness for that am i
just giving you money to buy more pink
[ __ ]
is that what i'm doing that's what i
want to know what
what am i buying this sandwich for you
know what's funny you know goddamn well
this somebody within that [ __ ] pink
organization is pulling down
high six figures for raising breast
cancer awareness you know they are
there's somebody right now down at some
[ __ ] dealership
going do i buy that overpriced shiny
[ __ ] or this one
right with [ __ ] he's got
pink [ __ ] 20s in his pocket gonna
peel them off like kanye west
right um kanye west
[Music]
that's my impersonation of his rapping
style
because he thinks his crowds are like
borderline [ __ ] and they don't
understand words so he has to slow down
every third one
i'm not saying i'm gonna [ __ ] a dick
[Music]
again
this they should re-break his jaw
because he still looks like a [ __ ]
pug
um oh i'm in a mood why ain't it such a
[ __ ] mood bill
i'll tell you why i'll tell you what
because i have a 14-hour flight today to
[ __ ] australia and i didn't want to
think about that but let's get back to
the pink [ __ ]
you know one of the classic things that
uh football fans will say they'll be
like but why don't they have
why don't they have prostate awareness
month
where they wear like brown stuff
you know why they don't have prostate um
awareness month
aside from the fact that guys couldn't
organize a [ __ ] fishing trip
without drinking a 12-pack first um
it's because guys are already watching
nfl football
that's why we're already watching
there's no way to
there's no re there's no what's the
upside
you know of that reminding us that our
ass might fall out someday while we're
watching the [ __ ]
overrated seahawks oh i'm going to get
to that by the way
i'm going to get to that all right you
tree hugging [ __ ]
kurt cobain candlelit vigil [ __ ]
douchebags
i'm gonna you know i'm gonna get to you
guys right [ __ ] now
i am so sick of them talking about how
[ __ ] well before i do that
let's be honest here the patriots did
not deserve to win that game tom brady
had a horrible [ __ ] game
um and our defensive backs just
i don't know what they're doing can
somebody
for the love of god explain to me what
the defensive backs on the new england
patriots are doing are they covering the
receivers
or are they just merely giving them an
escort down the field
we made that [ __ ] rookie look like
goddamn joe montana
the amount of [ __ ] jump balls that
guy threw just through a jump ball
in the general vicinity and our guys are
just running down the field
of course with these new [ __ ] uh
rules and this goes on on both sides the
the rules in the nfl
are just [ __ ] horrific at this point
do you see that jets game
luck andrew luck throws a pick
kromani's running it into the end zone
lux coming over to you know to try to
cause some sort of traffic so he goes
out of bounds and doesn't score and
guess what he gets blocked and he falls
on his ass
and they call a penalty roughing the
quarterback
i mean i i don't get it i don't it's one
of the worst [ __ ] calls i've ever
seen in my life other than that
[ __ ] call against the yankees at
second base now that that that right
there was um
i would investigate that umpire did you
have like
did you have money on that [ __ ] game
whatever whatever
whatever so that's [ __ ]
that whole the whole protecting of the
[ __ ] quarterback is such horseshit
there was one play the patriots one of
our linebackers came in
right seattle's quarterback is
in the follow through of throwing the
ball he goes to swat the ball the ball
goes by he misses it
and part of his forearm i mean hit the
guy's head
i mean not even hard he's swatting at
the ball they call roughing the passer
and that was yet another jump ball that
he threw and this is the coverage the
patriots guy has
he gives him his little little touch
you're allowed to touch the receiver
in within the first five yards but i
think at this point you're allowed to do
it
with only two fingers you know one
didn't index
fingers or two pinkies and a thumb okay
you're allowed because pinkies are
shorter you're allowed to touch the
[ __ ] receiver
and then after that you just all you can
do is
run next to them this is why
if i see one more mediocre [ __ ]
jackass
throw for 350 [ __ ] yards
it's unbeliev when i was a kid when you
played football you [ __ ] ran with
your guy
you saw his eyes and then you turned
around you looked back at the
quarterback and then you hand checked
the receiver you didn't grab his jersey
you just put your hand back so you knew
where the [ __ ] he was
okay that's it you can't even do that so
all these [ __ ] guys do now is they
just run down the field with them
and then when they see their eyes go up
at the last second they try to turn
around and by then it's it's [ __ ]
over
by the time they realize the ball's
there the receiver's [ __ ]
dick is in his face and then they just
sort of grab around his waist and pull
the guy down they're like oh
another big game for
joe blow he has 400 yards passing in the
second quarter
a new nfl record it's amazing he
couldn't carry dan marino's [ __ ]
jock strap but for some reason he just
broke one of his records
ah i i swear to god i am i'm gonna stop
[ __ ] watching nfl football
if you can't [ __ ] hit the quarterback
and you can't cover the receivers and i
have to watch
another [ __ ] guy go 36 for 58. i
don't want to see
58 six-yard passes in a game i don't
want to [ __ ] see it
i don't know maybe they'll make a helmet
that will allow
them to play football again and i want
to apologize to all those rugby
[ __ ] fans i was wrong after really
watching it this week you know i've been
on the road for six straight weeks after
really sitting down there
watching the nfl package dude i don't
even recognize the [ __ ] game anymore
do you know somebody but my buddy was is
back east in boston
do you see [ __ ] wes welker was a
tough son of a tough son of a [ __ ] did
you see him get [ __ ] stuck
after he made that catch just a [ __ ]
great old school rattle your fillings
hit
it was the [ __ ] one of those things
where you sit at home you see the hit
and you're like yeah right there
aside from obviously the speed of the
game that hit right there is why i'm on
the couch watching
and not playing because if that ever
happened to me i would have [ __ ] if i
didn't die instantly i would have been
crying
like a little girl and i would have
crawled off of my forearms
and just laid in the fetal position for
the rest of the [ __ ] game as opposed
to welker got up
was out for one play and came back and
counted like another 15 yarder
um just a great [ __ ] hit some [ __ ]
sports guy in boston my buddy was
telling me so that that the guy should
be
fine for that hit i don't know
this is it you know what it is the
timeout generation is coming of age
and uh i don't recognize it but i gotta
tell you
uh [ __ ] seattle their fans annoy the
[ __ ] out of me
they really do i am so sick of them
getting all this [ __ ] credit for
being this loud crowd
the 12th man you know your 12th man
should be it's your 12th man
every week should be the architect that
built that stadium
because they knew you guys were just
average [ __ ] fans
so they had to like design a symphony
hall
to enhance how loud your cheers are i
went to that stadium you can't [ __ ]
believe how loud it is
you're looking around going how is it
this loud and i'm looking at the
expressions on people's faces
they're not any more intense nothing
it's that [ __ ] overhang they built a
symphony
[Music]
to capture every [ __ ] cheer that goes
up there and now these guys are out
there act thinking they're like these
bad ass fans with your ugly ass [ __ ]
uniforms
ah and to make matters worse
yeah and every week they have some
[ __ ] b-list celebrity go out there
and i forget what he does he blows a
trumpet or raises a flag it was so
forgettable i was actually at
yeah it's half most of this is because
i'm mad that my [ __ ] team blew that
goddamn game
no we didn't blow we [ __ ] didn't even
deserve it we didn't [ __ ] deserve it
is this [ __ ] am i not taking away from
seattle yeah seattle totally deserves it
their [ __ ] defense is great
and everything was awesome and i really
liked i love how [ __ ] big and hard
their uh their their corners hit and
everything was great and then this
morning i watched the nfl network and
one of their corners is on there talking
trash but he's like
giddy it was like uh i had douche chills
going up the arm back down the arm and
back up the arms just like oh you know
before the game i said the radio were
going to beat you and he's like talk to
me after the game and then we won and
then i was like yeah what's up now
you know we're we're like a team they're
like they're like the brady bunch and
[Music]
ah it was like dude please stop talking
you just won just sit there like it was
no big deal
why are you trying to act like you're a
badass and you you sound
giddy you won a game in [ __ ] october
absolutely getting he sounded like he
shook
elvis's hand ugh
you can quote me put it on the nfl
network ow
go wash your dreads nobody gives a [ __ ]
well one for you when one [ __ ] game
you win one [ __ ] game
in october and you're [ __ ] sitting
there
texting about it and then tom brady said
this and then i said that
did he write some he said [ __ ] she
said horseshit
just be thankful that you have one more
[ __ ] victory than you really deserve
because of those replacement refs
honestly
seattle honestly do you really think
you're gonna win the super bowl this
year
you know even with your your your
enhanced acoustics there
you know who um actually you know to be
interesting um who
who who designed that stadium did paul
simon did he have a word in that
did he sit there on the 50-yard line you
know
singing one of his uh going to san
francisco songs
james taylor maybe he said out there
okay james let's just see if we've moved
the roof in
um far enough to capture every sound in
this building
i've seen fire and i've seen rain
i've seen sunny days
oh my god oh wait most of that most of
that was
i'm just pissed at my [ __ ] team lost
uh why won't they let them play football
anymore everybody
is it cuz they're worried about a
class-action suit with all these [ __ ]
concussions
just makes make him sign a waiver
i understand that if i get my head
slammed at 40 miles a [ __ ] hour every
three seconds playing this game
that eventually there might be some sort
of physical side effects
i take on all these personal [ __ ] uh
risks myself and i agree to go out there
and play football the way it was meant
to be played
i gotta tell you right now the two
biggest things ruining the game though
i mean you do have to protect the
players but the [ __ ] brady rule
i'm actually sitting there watching
brady and he's bugging me every time he
gets somebody runs by him too fast
he looks over at the ref it's just like
you know i it's it's it's
i'm gonna stop i'm not gonna stop
watching i'm just gonna keep bitching
because i have nothing better to do on a
[ __ ] sunday there's the truth in the
matter
but this [ __ ] dude back in the day
defensive backs man they had attitude
man they were up on their toes they were
right up on the line they got in your
face
they could [ __ ] intimidate you but
like
you can't even play defense it's like a
chaperone on a [ __ ]
prom night
i don't know but even if you could play
defense i swear to god our [ __ ]
corners are terrible
[ __ ] terrible i know i don't get the
[ __ ] game but you know what i can't
stand i [ __ ] hate zone defense
i hate when you're covering a guy and
then you just let him go
you let him go and then that other and
then he has like eight yards before
another guy's going to go pick him up
and then he's sitting down in the zone
sitting down in the zone he's not even
[ __ ] covered all right i got my
[ __ ] tampon out let's go
let's [ __ ] plow ahead here uh
i'm gonna go up there with a [ __ ]
hacksaw one day and i'm gonna cut off
the roof on both sides of those
of that [ __ ] stadium and and you know
what seattle seahawks fans
you're gonna find in an embarrassing way
how loud you truly are
okay when it immediately sounds like a
peter paul and mary concert
all right your granola bar eating
jackasses sitting there acting like
you're tough guys up there what do you
do
all you tough guys are out to see
getting the [ __ ] crab legs
what do you guys do huh sit around and
talk about the new world order
you know you're such rabid fans you lost
your basketball team go [ __ ] yourselves
um let's try neon green
hooray ah
jesus hey did you guys hear there's a
new strand of gonorrhea out there
this is a nice segue airborne
gonorrhea i really need an echo for that
airborne born born gonorrhea
airborne [ __ ] gonorrhea can you
believe that [ __ ]
just when you thought it was safe to
take your dick out
right here comes airborne gonorrhea
and we have evidently san diego state
university to thank for it
all right so there's a mysterious case
of this kid right he's never gotten laid
in his life he's kissed a couple of
girls but that's it and somehow he ends
up with [ __ ] gonorrhea
um so the doctors can't figure it out
let's pick it up here one question
about any physical contact or possible
mixing of fluids
the dude responded well i did sort of
brush up against this pretty girl's arm
but i don't think she noticed
so this kid as far as they're explaining
is basically
a virgin said after explaining his
situation
to the doctors at ucsd's student health
clinic
uh research began examining the peculiar
case
um this [ __ ] egghead was the first
guy to suspect a [ __ ] thing uh
a new strand of the disease sometimes
well here's what he said sometimes when
a bacterial disease is present
in extremely high quantities within a
relatively small location
read san diego state university campus
it can mutate and in some cases become
airborne
as it turns out this was the case at san
diego state university
and this virgin just happened to be the
first victim
that's how filthy these [ __ ] kids are
down there
jesus christ they must be going to class
barefoot
bunch of [ __ ] animals down there um
anyways
some chick who accompanied the virgin to
san diego state
said yeah it really sucks that the dude
who drove us
got gonorrhea
i mean he didn't even get any ass this
is a woman saying this
and still now look at him that really
blows
wow well there you go so there you go if
anybody has a daughter and you're
thinking about where not to send her
i would not send her to san diego state
university
why because of the the curriculum is
that he said the curriculum
the the safety issues on campus no
well well what is the reason it's
because of airborne board board gottaria
ria
airborne gonorrhea
that is just [ __ ] insane
san diego state gives you wings that
gives gonorrhea rings they're like the
[ __ ] red bull of stds
that is [ __ ] just shame on you san
diego state university
what are you guys doing down there i can
tell you what you're not doing
good [ __ ] lord get it you know what
they're going to invent a new condom
you know that just you you're going to
put it on like a [ __ ] bathing suit
and it's just going to cover everything
it'll be like a a speedo condom
you know but it's but it's very flexible
so you're still able to have some sort
of sex
it's just always see this [ __ ] it's over
this is nature man nature knows there's
just too many of us
and she's just i don't know what she's
doing
she needs to step up her game though
because if you think [ __ ] airborne
gonorrhea
is gonna stop us i gotta i got i got
news for you lady i don't i don't think
it is
you know i realize i am 22 minutes in i
always [ __ ] do this and i forget to
do the goddamn ads
by the way congratulations to sandy uh
seattle you know you know i'm [ __ ]
with you i'm just [ __ ] pissed that we
lost
all right before you send me all your
[ __ ]
you know i did an episode inside the nfl
this week and at the end of the end of
it i'm standing there with phil sims and
chris collinsworth who are two of the
funniest dudes
ever such a great experience doing that
show so they have me picking games so
i'm standing there with a guy
you know two guys who both played in
super bowls
and i'm just some [ __ ] from the stands
so i'm not really going to sit here and
give my picks
i'm just going to act like an idiot so i
predicted the patriots would win by 40.
i said the texans wouldn't win because i
didn't like their quarterback's face
i was going to pick tampa and then said
ah they got a pirate ship in their
stadium you know
they're not taking it seriously i just
did stuff like that the amount of people
who took it seriously
like you thought they were going to win
by 40. epic
fail it's like do you really think i
thought they were going to win by
unreal um unreal
um jim florenti my paul versi doing jim
florentine you gotta listen to paul
verzi's podcast by the way
um the uh i think it's the versi effect
i can't remember what the hell he calls
it
all i know is that robinson cano is oh
for 26 in his last 26
at bats he just he just
set a new playoff record nobody in the
history of the game has gone over
oh for 26.
you know what does verzi say rosie just
ah you know he's just in a slump
he's i got to talk yankee so here in a
second hold on here we go here we go
let's let's do some uh
let's do some reads here man um
all right what do i got here uh
all right mortgage rates just hit an
all-time historic low
3.125 apr
annual percentage rate for those of you
at home keeping score
um if you're looking for some extra cash
for the holiday season or just want to
take advantage of these rates
lendingtree can help you save hundreds a
month
can i tell you something if you want to
buy a house 3.125
is a great thing to do if you're so
broke you need to take out a second
mortgage to buy christmas gifts
i don't think that's a good idea extra
cash for christmas why would you do that
well it's probably the last week they
advertise um
don't do that okay you're gonna go buy a
bunch of
christmas gifts and not have a roof over
your head for god's sakes man let's
think this through
anyways it's easy it's free and you can
feel confident in the lender you choose
go to lendingtree.com and complete one
easy form
that takes less than five minutes to do
this is basically like you know when
you're going to like uh
maybe gonna go down to san diego and
avoid san diego state university campus
and you want to find a cheap hotel what
is it like orbits this is like the
orbits of of mortgages
you just pump in you know what you're
looking for all your information
and they will scan all these different
banks at your fingertips
and you will get the lowest rate but
please do not take out a second mortgage
oh they're not saying that they're just
saying if you just want some cash
for christmas you know i think at that
point you got to go chop down a tree and
just make a wooden train for somebody
and do the best you can that's what i
would do
um a couple of iou slips all right
plumbing ahead
uh bill uh anyways you will be able to
compare offers from up to four lenders
and if you enter the code bur b-u-r-r
you will receive a free mortgage
guide um
and there you go 3.125 percentage rate
that's
that's unbelie i have a nice percentage
rate on my house
all right i thought i had it good and
all of a sudden look at these guys
it's even lower and i know what you're
thinking well why don't you refinance
bill i'll tell you why because after all
the rig of a row it's going to cost me
more money so i'm locked into my rate
all right if you want to get locked into
a better rate right now now's the time
get yourself you know what's great about
house if you just pay that thing down
you know when the apocalypse comes you
own your thing
you own your little hut as everybody
else is getting thrown out by the
bankers
coming down the street like the penguin
in the old batman movies
um you know who's getting who if you're
gonna pay for 30 years
to have the one of the low all-time
historic low interest rate there you go
all right bill we got it we got it um
and then of course the classic
stamps.com do you like going to the post
office
really well what's wrong with you
wouldn't it be great if you didn't have
to go to the post office because you
could do everything that you could do at
the post office
within your own home dwelling or tent
city um
this is the basic you can print legal
stamps
at any hour of the day all right
you get a postage meter stamps.com has
no hidden fees
um oh unlike a post-its meter stamps.com
has no hidden fees
like meter ink charges or reset fees no
long-term contracts no extra hardware
to buy or lease stamps.com can save you
up to 80 percent
compared to a postage meter plus
stamps.com
with stamps.com you can do more with the
with the meter
come on bill let's focus here use your
existing
address books sending track information
to recipients with a click of the button
the choice is clear stamps.com offers
features at a fraction of the cost
i use stamps.com whenever i send out any
of my dvds
and uh i absolutely love it i love it
um use use my last name bur for for my
special offer no risk trial plus 110
bonus offer includes a digital scale and
up to 55 dollars free postage
you just try it you're up 55 bucks where
in this economy can you do that
don't wait go to stamps.com before you
do anything else click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
burr burr that's stamps.com
enter bur all right back to the podcast
and once again congratulations to the
seattle seahawks i really don't hope
that you don't win a
super bowl all right before you get all
[ __ ] upset
actually we are that loud back when we
had when we had the uh the kingdom
and people painted their heads man
um we were shotgunning granola bars man
the new world order um
actually i love uh i love seattle it's a
[ __ ] beautiful city you know what i
mean
and it's worth sitting there talking to
those broads with the hairy bushes
um the [ __ ] new york yankees i gotta
tell you i was just in new york city
new york new york and um
i got to tell you something joe girardi
sitting a-rod pinch hitting him
in the ninth inning when they're down
sitting a 200 million dollar man might
is arguably
the ballsiest gutsiest move i've ever
seen by
not only a baseball manager i'm trying
to think of a gutsy or call
i know saints fans oh what about when we
did the onside kick not even close
not even close that's just some uh
razzle dazzle you just yeah that's you
file that under that [ __ ]
this this was an unbelievable move it
was such an unreal move
for those who didn't watch and were
under a rock
the guy uh raulula bagnes who looks like
i don't know what he looks like he looks
like
an older freddy krueger he's an
old guy put it that way i'm four years
older than him so i look even worse
guy hits a home run it's like a movie
it's like robert redford in the natural
goes into extra innings they went in on
a walk-off home run by who
none other than raul labanes again it
was i just was unreal and
i absolutely hate the yankees and the
next day i'm reading the new york post
reading about this historic move and i'm
smiling
reading about a yankee win unbelievable
i actually got into the baseball
playoffs a little bit
because uh i kept doing spots um
all that whole week i was getting ready
to do night of too many stars
on comedy central which i taped
uh saturday night and will air i believe
within the week
raises money for autism and
i kept making fun of that name night of
too many stars there's too many stars
and then i showed up and saw who was
there and that was pretty impressive i'm
not going to ruin it
but uh i was definitely my head was on a
swivel
i saw half of my childhood walk by um
anyways yeah so i would go out and i
would run my set
and um and then i would i would at the
end of the night
i'd go to this bar by myself
i get a whiskey and i would just sit
there and i would would watch the end of
the games
and uh what did i watch i watched oh my
god i watched the [ __ ]
i was gonna say the senators the [ __ ]
uh nationals
i watched the nationals oh my god that
[ __ ]
that debacle that was brutal that was
like
the old school red sox that was the way
the red sox used to lose
that was brutal so my condolences to
national fans i sat there watching it
not really giving a [ __ ] about the
series but i was like oh they've never
won
they won the playoff series in baseball
since the 1930s i got to watch this
because these fans are going to go crazy
go crazy folks they're going to go nuts
and just watching that
just watching it go away
what the hell were they were they down
by four runs
no what was it no they scored four runs
it was seven to five
they're one strike away and next thing
you know it's nine to seven
cardinals oh it was brutal
it was brutal that was i saw two
horrific things that and watching derek
jeter break his ankle
and have to get carried off the field
that was just that was not something
that i wanted to see
had i known that that was going to
happen i i wouldn't have watched
you know you don't want to see derek
jeter carried off the field it was it
was brutal
[ __ ] brutal so anyways hats off to uh
joe girardi man that was an awesome
oh what a gutsy call to have to walk up
to him
and be like yeah listen i'm about ready
to humiliate you
in front of the country for the better
of this team
and uh if this doesn't work out
you know with the way the new york media
is they might actually question uh
are they gonna question whatever the
[ __ ] i do and he still had the nerve to
do it
unreal unreal
um anyways here we go hey bill i'm a
huge fan and i just want to let you know
that recently my mother
has been battling cancer while she's in
the hospital recovering from surgery my
dad brother and i sat down and watched
your special even though it might have
been an hour of the day you made us
laugh
at a time when we all really needed why
we why we this is like really nice we
don't do nice things in the podcast
i truly believe
thank you very much thank you okay well
i'm glad i was able to do that
i'm glad my total ego trip look at me
selfish thing that i do somehow added to
your life and i'm sorry to hear about
your mom i hope she gets better
all right see now now now we're in this
place
now we're in this place this happened to
me on that night of too many stars i'm
not going to say what happened but i had
to go on
after something that really should have
just ended the show
because it was unreal it was unreal and
i was literally standing there going i
have to go on after this why why
oh geez but the host hooked me up the
host got him back got him back to a more
sillier place
um anyways the host jon stewart um
solid guy stand up comedian
saw the situation all right took the
bullet
for me brought me out nice solid guy
all right facebook comments bill how
does someone who can hardly read
write a book
you know how i can do that sir um
i i didn't write a book i wrote it with
two of my friends
we all held each other you know they
brought me across the finish line like
kellen winslow in that game against the
dolphins
um that's actually not true me and bobby
carry joe derosa across the finish line
you know not because joe's not a piece
of [ __ ] joj is just such a commitment
phobe he's never really in a
relationship so he didn't have that many
cheating stories
um but anyways i want to thank everybody
who's going out and buying the book the
book has been doing phenomenally
[Music]
whatever the hell is the book charts so
if you haven't got your
your copy of cheat a man's guide to
infidelity
absolutely hilarious over-the-top look
at uh
men's behavior and the dumb things that
we do
um we got a bunch of our knucklehead
friends telling stories about cheating
on women
and getting caught and then the three of
us me joe and bobby basically
break down their cheat stories like nfl
game film and try to say where they went
wrong where they went right
and in the back of the book the true
reason we wrote the book was to hype our
short film that we got into
the tribeca film festival called cheat
um
you get a link to the movie and you can
check it out and it's awesome so
thank you for everybody and also my
special you people are all the same is
still available for download at
billboard.com and if you're having
problems downloading it
you have totally my empathy because i
would screw it up too because i
am also not good at the computer the art
of computers
just make sure when you just in this if
you have a problem all you need to do is
in capital letters in the subject line
this will help me find your email
quickly and get you the special as
quickly as possible just write
stand up special and then in the body of
your email
just have your paypal receipt copied and
we'll get it right out to you
okay because if you just say hey i
bought it i couldn't download it
i have to do the extra thing of going
okay send me the receipt we'll get it to
you it's an extra step
all right we're trying to expedite
the process of you getting this special
all right speaking of special led
zeppelin special mr burr
tell me you're excited about the new led
zeppelin film about their 2007 benefit
concert
um jim florente talked about it on his
most recent podcast and mentioned how
bonzo's son
stole the show yeah jason i actually
talked to florentine well texted about
it he said was the best concert film
he's ever seen
um and i also heard that the members of
the band were
were ridiculously excited after they saw
it
so he goes so i thought that this might
be the best dilemma question for you
if you could see only one last concert
would you choose
ac dc in argentina or led zeppelin with
bonzo's son
ah i'd uh that's that's actually an easy
one i would have to say led zeppelin
with bonzo son just for the
simple fact that i've seen ac dc a bunch
of times and i've never seen led
zeppelin
and um
as much as i would love to see ac dc in
argentina yeah i would i would go see
zeppelin you know what i i mean because
i i saw some clips of it what i liked
about how jason played
was you could just tell that
he wasn't intimidated by the moment you
know that poor guy
he basically he had to follow the
greatest drummer of all time his dad
it'd be like if you were jordan's son
and you're playing hoop even if you dunk
on somebody someone's going yeah but
your dad
your dad would have jumped higher he's
had to deal with that his entire life
and i just felt the way he was playing
he didn't give a [ __ ]
what anybody was gonna say and he did
this great blend
of um stuff that his dad played
on the classic recordings and stuff that
i've heard on the zeppelin bootlegs
he kind of blended those perfectly while
also
just being in the moment himself i felt
like and throwing in some [ __ ] that
his interpretations and he it was it was
perfect he did the perfect balance
of of staying true to the original and
then adding his own
flavor to it without getting in the way
it was an absolute masterpiece so
um there you go look at that after
coming out hard
coming out hard and trashing pink shirts
and everybody in seattle look at them
coming around here
giving uh giving [ __ ] props to the
yankees and [ __ ]
jesus christ almighty um anyways
barrel bella beer oh beer
um fear of stds and downgrading
um what's going on bill love the podcast
and all the advice
you have gail you know [ __ ] this i'm not
gonna read this right now let's talk
about how the i have to get on a [ __ ]
airplane today
to fly to australia all right which
is definitely exciting exciting and new
get on board what are you
going to do you're [ __ ] trapped here
for [ __ ] 14 goddamn hours
you have two options sit there and take
it or do permanent damage to your liver
by taking some sleep aids
yeah i don't know what i'm gonna do i'm
not into those [ __ ] ambiance and all
those types of things because uh i do
enough damage to my
liver with [ __ ] whiskey and all that
type of [ __ ] i don't need
i don't need to be adding to it you know
what i mean you know like when the ref
gets knocked down in a wrestling match
and then and and the hero guy with the
blonde blonde [ __ ] mullet is over in
the bad guys corner
and the guy who's not supposed to be in
he's got his foot on his [ __ ] throws
the other guy kicks him in the head
allegedly
yeah i don't want to be doing that to my
[ __ ] liver
so i actually tweeted this out these
these are basically my options for a 14
hour flight 14 [ __ ] hours
14 [ __ ] out what are we what are we
going by ship here huh
what what are we doing here um
all right first option i watch all three
godfathers
plus goodfellas and then i try and sleep
for six hours that'll be 14 hours
or i
take a fistful of ambien and i watch
raising arizona
and then i'm there but i've done this
flight before and i did it out in new
york city and i i flew
with this lady and she took some of
those drugs
and i kept looking over her jealous as
she just slept
hour after hour after hour and i was
sitting there [ __ ] playing tetris for
like [ __ ] eight hours
um um
well but at the end of the flight when
when she went to get off
i swear to god she looked like she got
the [ __ ] kicked out of her but for some
reason her face
had didn't have the bruises but it was
all puffy she looked horrible
and uh i don't want to do that [ __ ]
so i think i'm going to go with the
[ __ ]
yeah but my laptop's going to run out of
battery life
did ever tell you guys how i don't like
that movie casino
it's just too [ __ ] violent it's it's
just too [ __ ] violent i love all the
other stuff in it but that [ __ ] with a
guy's eye gets popped out
or were they making pesce watch them
beat his brother to death with the bat
and they're like burying him while he's
still
[ __ ] half conscious it's just it just
it's just too much just [ __ ] rubbed
me the wrong way
those fake deaths i couldn't handle
um [ __ ] so what am i going to do
i'm taking the lovely neil with me of
course of course she wants to go
she never goes when i need her like when
i'm going to [ __ ] you know some
god-forsaken place you know if i'm going
someplace fun oh she's right there on my
hip
you know how ladies do that oh i wanna
go
that sounds like fun oh yeah
how come jacksonville doesn't sound like
fun what about cincinnati you
don't think you can have some fun there
that's the great thing about this trip
is i had fun in all those places
i had an unbelievably great time in
jacksonville
shooting guns eating gator going to the
game and then i went up to [ __ ]
cincinnati and i ate their [ __ ] ribs
i took a river boat over to the game
i had a great i had a great time i
really did
um oh and speaking of a great time
this is totally just free advertisement
there's a new stand-up comedy club in
new york city
there's a new girl in town and she's
feeling good um jesus christ what was
that that was
that was alice i didn't always knew that
there's a new girl in town
and she's feeling good
got a divorce and a big tooth kid and
we're going to arizona because i'm gonna
tan up my milf titties
i forget how it goes anyways
that dude was a cute kid and then once
he [ __ ] he once he grew up wow
he went through his [ __ ] awkward
years all of a sudden he had giant
[ __ ] teeth
and he didn't look so good tommy
tommy was his name um
the [ __ ] am i talking about why did i
just start singing oh a new stand-up
club
the guys who run the club right now are
[ __ ] sitting on the edge of their
seats going is this [ __ ] adt
add douche bag actually going to get to
it and yes i am
um there's a new new comedy club it's
called the stand it's on third avenue
between 19th and 20th street and
um has unbelievable food and there's a
great comedy room downstairs
and i hung out there all [ __ ] weekend
all week building up for the night of
too many stars
and uh i had an awesome time and that's
definitely going to be a regular stop
for me
when i come back to new york and you
should it's just [ __ ] great it's
great place to take abroad
they got good food great comedy
downstairs and um
yeah it's kind of the same setup as the
uh
the comedy cellar you know restaurant
upstairs
comedy room downstairs you know
they're like a smaller version of that
so either or
there you go the comedy seller the
classic
the fillmore of stand-up comedy clubs
in new york city and now there's another
new one
stan you know i actually went around and
i did all the old ones man i had a great
time going back there i did
uh did a spot at danger fields did a
couple spots at the comic strip
i went over to uh stand-up new york
uh went down to the cellar it was great
it was [ __ ] great time and then i
really actually missed
being able to do like four spots in a
night
working on stuff um
that was a great time in my life way
back in the day late 90s early 2000s
when i was
when i was living with [ __ ] bobby
kelly and we would go out and do like
eight shows
on a friday eight shows on saturday
the [ __ ] end of the night sitting
there all sweaty with [ __ ]
50 bucks 50 bucks a spot whether that be
400 bucks
i've told these stories and i always had
to take cabs because i played downtown
and uptown and bobby played he played
the boston the juan the seller
and some nights he'd do three at each
and he'd have nine and he'd have to take
one
[ __ ] cab and he had all his money and
i'd be jealous
anyways fear of stds and downgrading
what's going on bill i love the podcast
and all the advice you've given
no matter how inane so i thought i'd ask
for some advice for myself
uh for the last year and a half i've
been tormented by my ex-girlfriend
she dumped me and did the whole i want
you back thing on and off for a year and
a half
oh my god dude which is longer than we
were together
in parentheses only a year i don't want
to be with
i don't want to be with her because i
now know how much of a [ __ ] she is but
the problem is that i've been lured into
this [ __ ] for that period of time
you've learned to watch [ __ ] back into
the relationship
um anyways he says even though during
that time we were not together
i didn't sleep with or do anything with
any other girl
to make me look like the bigger person
in the situation she had a boyfriend
during this time because
again she's a [ __ ] um
well dude you're a sap all right
you if if you're just going to say she's
a [ __ ] here like
you're you're turning the keys over to
the relay of the whole [ __ ]
relationship to her
that the reason why this isn't working
is because she's a [ __ ] she
she is a [ __ ] and you're allowing her
[ __ ] missed
to [ __ ] come into your atmosphere
sorry i know
i ran out of [ __ ] there um yeah
she's like airborne gonorrhea get away
from her
all right get away from her anyways he
goes so i
i haven't had sex in over a year and a
half which is slowly killing me on the
inside dude what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you
don't you have any friends have you told
your guy
friends that
ah come on man you're better than this
he says and the prospects aren't looking
too good
not many attractive ladies at my school
and the ones who are attractive
i'd probably rather date since i'm more
of a relationship guy
um i've never had a one-night stand
before and would not know how to handle
a situation just approaching a girl
and getting her to have sex with me
within a couple of hours
it's not like i don't want to have
random sex but i am
worried of stds and do not want to don't
want to just bang some ugly
not too attractive broad since my ex was
extremely attractive
i do not want to downgrade in any sense
well you don't you don't have to
bang some pig dude you just need to go
out this is what you need to do you need
to go out first thing you need to do is
go down to the thrift shop get yourself
a [ __ ] smoking jacket
and some slippers all right and just
start [ __ ] walking around and just
feeling that vibe
you have to stop giving a [ __ ] all right
get yourself a bunch of condoms
you know that's a great thing to do get
yourself a bunch of condoms like you're
preparing for something wonderful to
happen
and then just get out there in the game
don't give don't go out there going like
i have to convince this girl to have sex
with me tonight
you know that's you're going to come off
desperate
just go out there and just [ __ ] have
a good time i'm telling you right now
it's like doing stan
half are doing stand-up is if you're up
there having the [ __ ] time of your
life
the crowd's going to go along with you
they like it they see you having fun
it's contagious they want to be around
you you just go out have a good time at
a [ __ ] party
crack some jokes say what's up be
friendly don't freak them out
and eventually what's your deal what's
going on with you and they do a little
touch on your arm right there you're at
least rounded second
you know that's it baby steps hit a
double first before you worry about
[ __ ] hitting the cycle
um that would be my advice to you even
though i haven't read the rest so i
don't even know what your [ __ ]
question is so let's let's plow ahead
although now i've also brought up
airborne born gonorrhea
real get a gas mask and some condoms and
i think you ought to be good
that's gonna be sex here in the next
couple of years do you like that does
that feel good
oh yeah yeah yeah shake my dick
hey hey yeah suck my dick
my dick yes jesus christ
[ __ ] idiot
i didn't i wasn't talking to you i
wasn't
hey are you gonna [ __ ] leave me you
gotta [ __ ] live great great we'll
[ __ ] you
you [ __ ] here take your ear we're
gonna really with you [ __ ]
that's gonna be sex in a couple of uh
a couple of years
is that gonna be a campaign issue in the
next few years
i'm gonna be tougher on healthcare i'm
gonna get schools back and we're gonna
tackle the problem
head-on of airborne gonorrhea
um let's just get to his [ __ ]
question here i'm also on a college
budget and definitely do not want to
spend extra money
i have on taking some girl out to dinner
or some [ __ ] well then go [ __ ] yourself
dude have fun
jerking off you know what there's your
opening line yeah listen i want to [ __ ]
you tonight but like i don't want to
waste any money
so wow what do you say
i'll take it out myself you know you
know don't worry unless you want to you
know burn some calories
take it out more duke um so i am
wondering if i should stop spending so
much time thinking about getting late
and just focusing on my
focus on myself until i graduate and let
whatever happens happens
yeah that's great should i just take my
hand off the wheel and see where the car
goes
or should i just say [ __ ] it and try to
[ __ ] the next girl who gives me
attention
no don't do that all right you're a
relationship
guy you don't want to go down that
[ __ ] road okay but also
you know even though you are a
relationship guy if you're the next one
you meet is the one
and you get married you're gonna be it's
gonna bug you that you didn't go out and
bang at least [ __ ] 20 30 girls so
i would you know quality sir
quality okay make a list
check it twice so you don't [ __ ] some
[ __ ] who's got the [ __ ] lice
[Music]
um all right tattoos
all right i know they're all the [ __ ]
rage but
you know that says something about you
if you get a tattoo i don't give a [ __ ]
all right you're definitely on the other
side of the skank fence
all right um the way a girl dresses
you want a girl who dresses classy all
right
not like a [ __ ] [ __ ] she dresses
like a [ __ ] okay a sports car
looks like a sports car and has been
driven like one okay
you look at a girl who's dressed like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] she has been she's been
ridden like one you understand
all the [ __ ] time all right
look you know those classic girls can be
a lot of fun too
they really can they actually can have a
conversation with him you're a
relationship guy
you know you just walk in hey what's
going on with you i'm getting out of the
relationship
you know i just stated you know this
absolute psycho she's completely [ __ ]
with my head
i'm not even trying to be in a
relationship you know just hit her with
that [ __ ] because i'm actually a
relationship guy oh he's sensitive maybe
we'll get a puppy someday
and you'll [ __ ] be in there
and then you know i don't know what i
don't know what you do these day you put
on some
skrillex or dead mouse and you [ __ ]
whip it
up and then you [ __ ] come in her face
um am i dating a [ __ ] hey bill
greetings from spain hola
me amigo when are you coming here
i'm going to come there and watch people
get run over by bulls at some point
and i've realized that the place to be
at is you want to be in the arena where
there's nowhere left to run
you know um anyway i'm 22 and need some
advice about a girl i'm dating she was
in class with me in high school
dude are you bilingual and you write
this was just [ __ ] amazing my whole
spanish fell off again because i can't
find a disc to put it on this
[ __ ] laptop it's only on my old one
the worst
um two months or so ago we met again
for my best friend's birthday wait let's
start over again i already forgot what
happened
she was in class with me in high school
we were good friends at the time two
months ago we met again for my best
friend's birthday party
she fit in my group of friends pretty
well and after a couple days we started
flirting with each other
finally one night we hooked up and now
we're dating great what could go wrong
two years ago she quit her career in
college and i picked
another one that she liked
two years ago she quit her career in
college and i picked another one that
she liked i don't know what that means
she had to move to madrid to attend
school
yesterday we were having a small small
pillow talk
and i asked her how many guys she'd bang
she started counting and my [ __ ]
shrunk a little
turns out when she was in madrid she
[ __ ] six guys in six months
and then started a relationship with
another one that went for a year and a
half
uh they broke up a month ago and now
she's with me so if my math doesn't fail
counting her
first boyfriend the six dude that she's
[ __ ] in this last guy i'm dick number
nine
i've slept with six women in my entire
life and somehow i feel like i'm dating
a [ __ ]
dude she's still in signal digits
you know that ain't nine dicks you're a
number nine
eight trying to think of the schoolhouse
[ __ ] rock song for eight was there
one
three's a magic number
number nine will put you
on the spot
[Laughter]
number nine
i've slept with six women might so i'm
i've slept with six with my entire life
and somehow i feel like i'm dating a
[ __ ] i can't help but have
this horrendous thought in my head i'm
not a jealous guy
at all but i caught myself a couple
times on her facebook page
guessing who these dudes are dude don't
do that to yourself look you're
competitive
all right you know you have six td
passes she has nine
she's going she's starting the pro bowl
uh
she's sweet she's nice she's into me but
i think it will be
different for me to trust this girl
which
had never happened to me before i'm
feeling miserable any advice will be
appreciated
yeah dude it's not her fault you only
bang six broads
all right it'd be one thing if she had
um
a history of cheating on guys she was in
a relationship with
um look put it this way
a woman if she's even just halfway
decent looking can go out to a bar and
get
dick every [ __ ] night all right now
if you could do that if you could turn
the [ __ ] table if you could go out
and get laid like that
with women how many women women would
you have banged
in [ __ ] six months 180
is what i'm gonna say six months 30 days
a [ __ ] month
roughly yeah you probably would bang
you'd probably bang 80 before you
started thinking what am i doing this is
empty
you know she banged six
she that was probably her [ __ ] little
little uh
she got it out of her system you know
she's not [ __ ] around on you she's
not a [ __ ] it's just making you uh
uh i didn't consider it what's the word
insecure
you're all right dude nine in this day
and age with airborne gonorrhea i mean
that's pretty that's a pretty [ __ ]
low number
and she did it all in spain way away
from san diego state university
home of airborne gonorrhea ria
do you think they're gonna put that in
their [ __ ] brochure you know every
every s
college has to be number one in
something
oh my god who's their big rival in
football
but you guys got to make the airborne
gonorrhea [ __ ] t-shirts
show up with gas masks on for those
dirty
filthy [ __ ] students the fact that
the [ __ ] chick
from the goddamn school is sitting there
going in the sad thing he didn't even
get any ass
right there that a [ __ ] lady would
talk like that
let you know why there's airborne
gonorrhea
oh you [ __ ] skank um
all right e-voice everybody if you need
help looking for more for more
uh looking more professional or being
more efficient you should check out
e-voice
i personally have received some really
great feedback from listeners on twitter
um that show you guys are really liking
uh e-voice
and why wouldn't [ __ ] by going to
e-voice by going to www.evoice.com
billboard you can get a free six-month
trial of e-voice
it helps me as i can now give out
multiple numbers that will
all come through one cell phone why do
they keep making it me seem like i d
i'm not using these products i would use
it though i do endorse it if i was
trying to start a business i would
all right but i'm not gonna sit here and
lie to the listeners the listeners
um you can have virtual answering
service with multiple accents that make
you sound bigger than you uh
transcribe your voicemails to text or
email basically e-voice makes your life
easier it makes a small business owner
look much bigger
my favorite thing is the professional
voice over actors actors and actresses
that will give you any accent you want
and sound all good-looking and stuff and
make people want to go to your business
go to www.evoy billboard and you can get
you can get a free six-month trial of
e-voice
um and once again lending tree if you
want to take advantage of the extremely
low rates 3.125 percent you can act now
um you can save hundreds and it'll take
you just minutes by going to
um to try lendingtree.com these rates
aren't going to stay like this forever
go to trylandingtree.com complete one
simple form
and the network of over 200 lenders will
send you four customized loan offers
you can't do any better than that and
the last two let me just get these out
of the way amazon.com
holiday shopping starting uh if you'd
like to donate to this podcast and the
wounded warriors project just go to
billboard.com click on the podcast page
click on the amazon banner
anything you buy after that on amazon
they'll give me a piece i kicked
a piece of the piece over to the wounded
warriors project
and there you go and that's it
okay bill what am i doing i'm originally
from massachusetts i recently
got out of the army infantry and i'm now
living in hawaii
there you go huh that's that's a good
deal
he goes it's not as good as it sounds
okay all right well there goes all that
happiness
i stayed here because i fell in love
with a smoking hot local girl she's 29
with three kids
all from the same guy but he's a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] in and out of jail for
being
a meth head like most hawaiians
anyway sometimes i feel trapped here
playing daddy i'm 25 years old
been all over the world done my time in
the military now i'm going
to school to be a firefighter at a
[ __ ] college where only
six percent of the people are white and
they [ __ ]
hate white people well the white people
hate white people
all right but it's kind of good deal
because her grandfather is a retired
federal fire chief
so in a year i can be in the firehouse
i don't know what to do she and the kids
aren't too bad honestly
it's all [ __ ] amazing but i still
feel trapped in this [ __ ] twilight
zone [ __ ] life
where i've got three kids and a wife air
quote
another option is i'm back in mass
drinking beers and trying to avoid
getting any felony convictions
i don't [ __ ] know man sometimes i
just feel like i'm letting the best
years of my life get away from me
then i think maybe these are the best
years of my life and i start
crying into my [ __ ] beer you got any
advice
i need a new point of view on this whole
thing thanks man jesus dude this is a
[ __ ] dilemma
you know you gave me just enough
information to still be
all right are you gonna marry this girl
do you love her like that when you're 35
she's 39
you're 65 she's 69 you know is she going
to have any more kids with you how many
kids do you want how many more kids does
she want
you know they got fires in massachusetts
too you know
so you can always be a firefighter
wherever the [ __ ] you go
um are you ready for all of this is what
you got to ask yourself
you know it sounds like you're pretty
happy you're living in a paradise
you know with those volcanoes there
you're always going to have work
there's always going to be some fires
right
you know when the dollar collapses well
there's still a zillion people there you
can still have some [ __ ] going on
um yeah dude this is up to you i hate to
say that
i mean when i was 25 years old i was not
ready to be living in hawaii
with a woman four years older than me
with three [ __ ] kids
i was not ready to do that um
so i understand wait
if you're feeling [ __ ] like that i
definitely get that but i also hadn't
traveled the [ __ ] world
fought in a war and done all the stuff
that you've done you've lived way more
life than i have
at 25. so um
yeah you just got to ask yourself those
questions what the [ __ ] do you want to
do
you know smoking hot local girls 29
got three kids uh you know on the
[ __ ] beach why don't you make friends
with woody harrelson and get some
[ __ ] weed
i'm sorry dude i don't know what to tell
you this is one you know what you're
gonna have to be on your own in this one
this is too big a [ __ ] decision
too big a decision i would just say do i
love this girl is she the one
or am i just here because she's [ __ ]
smoking hot
and you know doesn't have any tan lines
that's what i would ask myself all right
that's the podcast for this week
um tonight i am flying
to sydney australia 14 [ __ ] hours
hopefully there'll be no
airborne gonorrhea on the [ __ ] plane
um oh [ __ ] me
this is gonna suck but once i land it's
gonna be awesome
and um i'm gonna [ __ ] uh
i'm gonna have great shows out there i'm
really excited i got three nights of
shows
as far as i know i think they're all
sold out and uh so thank you for all the
podcast listeners out there in sydney
for stepping it up
and uh oh and also another thing about
rugby i've got some guy sent me a story
some guy lost his
ball in the first half of the rugby game
and he played the rest of the [ __ ]
way
so whatever all right i would put
the way the nfl used to be up against
rugby now
um my buddy joe bartnick who's got a new
cd coming out is going to be on
hyping his cd here in a couple of weeks
when he releases it said the funniest
thing to me he said if you want to watch
how nfl football used to be watch
sec football so there you go so if
you're an old [ __ ]
nfl head like me and you're a little
disappointed with the escort that the
[ __ ] quarterbacks do now as they run
down the field
and how you can't block a [ __ ]
quarterback after you just threw a
[ __ ] interception and he's basically
trying to make a play
uh sec football pick a team alabama lsu
georgia florida south carolina
vanderbilt tennessee
arkansas mississippi mississippi state
who the [ __ ] did i forget
kentucky and somebody [ __ ] else
auburn
war eagle they're all [ __ ] great
great to watch
um that's it that's the podcast for this
week go [ __ ] yourselves
i'm bringing my mixer all the way over
to sydney australia
uh we're gonna have great time out there
and uh we'll give you some photos and
all that type of [ __ ] all right
that's it go [ __ ] yourselves please
watch night of too many stars this week
on um um on comedy central
and thanks to everybody at inside the
nfl i it was a dream come true to be
able to do that show
and um for all fans of that show
um i i can't tell you how how hilarious
everybody was it was such a good time
just the ball breaking that those guys
do it's like you're in a locker room
you know that's all they do is give each
other [ __ ] and when we would be in
between
segments you know they were like
just egging me on give us more [ __ ] give
us more [ __ ] they were just just totally
just couldn't have been nicer uh which
ended up being great for me because i i
really didn't even feel worthy to be on
the show so thank you to those guys
um and that's it that's the podcast all
right go [ __ ] yourselves i'll talk to
you next week